ใช่
ก็คือเดินหน้าต่อไป ทั้ง bits
และ qubits จะเป็นรากฐานของการคำนวณ
ที่เราจะใช้รับมือกับ
ปัญหาที่ซับซ้อนในโลกนี้
งั้นมาทำความเข้าใจความแตกต่างระหว่างสองสิ่งนี้กัน
และดูว่าพลังของ qubits มาจากไหน
ถ้าดูที่ด้านซ้ายมือ
นี่คือวิธีอธิบาย และเราจะใช้ diagram พวกนี้
ตลอดการนำเสนอ เพื่อ
แสดงให้เห็นถึงพลัง เราเห็นวงกลม
และจุดสองจุด เมื่อจุดอยู่ที่ขั้วเหนือ
นั่นคือศูนย์ เมื่ออยู่ที่ขั้วใต้คือหนึ่ง
นั่นคือ classical bit สองสถานะ ส่วน qubit คือ
หน่วยของข้อมูลในโลกควอนตัม
และตรงนี้เราจะได้เล่นกับรูปภาพ
เหมือน sphere ที่เป็นทั้งศูนย์และหนึ่ง
และเราสามารถให้มันอยู่ใน superposition state ได้
เรามีกลเม็ดพิเศษที่ใช้ได้
ไม่เพียงแต่วางตำแหน่งมันบน sphere ได้
แต่ลองนึกภาพว่าแต่ละตัว
เหมือนดวงจันทร์เล็กๆ
ที่อยู่บน sphere และเราหมุนดวงจันทร์ได้
ดังนั้นตรงนี้จะเห็นว่า
sphere ด้านล่างถูกหมุนเล็กน้อย
นั่นเลยเห็นสีน้ำเงินนิดหน่อย
และสีชมพู แล้วเราหมุนได้จนสุด
นี่คือการหมุน 180 องศา
เราจึงมีแนวคิดเรื่อง phase ที่ควอนตัมมอบให้เรา
มีพลังพิเศษสามอย่างที่แสดงอยู่ใน qubits
ได้แก่ พลังของ superposition
พลังของ interference
และพลังของ entanglement
มาดูสิ่งเหล่านี้กัน หลักการของ superposition จริงๆ แล้ว
เข้าใจได้ไม่ยากเลย
ดาวที่อยู่ทางซ้ายมือ
เราเลือกได้ว่าจะเป็นขั้วเหนือ-ศูนย์ หรือขั้วใต้-หนึ่ง
และถ้าเรารวมสองสถานะนั้น
เราก็จะได้ superposition qubit ที่มีทั้ง
ศูนย์และหนึ่งพร้อมกัน ทั้งขั้วเหนือ
และขั้วใต้ diagram ทางขวาเหมือนกัน
แต่คราวนี้เราจะทำกลเม็ดเล็กน้อย
เราจะใช้ gate หนึ่งตัว — quantum gate
สิ่งที่เราทำตรงนี้คือ จำไว้ว่า
เราเปลี่ยนได้ เราสามารถ
หมุนดวงจันทร์เล็กๆ พวกนี้ได้
เราหมุนมันไป 100
กว่าๆ องศา และตอนนี้เราได้หนึ่ง
ดังนั้นเมื่อเราบวกศูนย์กับหนึ่ง เราได้
superposition state
แต่สังเกตว่ามันต่างออกไป
ตัวทางซ้าย เรายัง
เป็นศูนย์กับหนึ่ง แต่ตอนนี้อยู่ในสถานะที่ถูกหมุน
สำหรับหนึ่งนั้น จะทรงพลังมากขึ้น
เมื่อนำไปใช้กับสิ่งที่น่าสนใจอันดับสองซึ่งก็คือ
หลักการของ interference
และนี่ไม่ใช่ operation ที่ทำได้ใน classical
bit โลก ในตัวอย่างนี้เรามี
ศูนย์กับหนึ่งทางซ้าย บวกกับ
สถานะใหม่ที่เราสร้างขึ้น
ซึ่งก็เป็นศูนย์กับหนึ่งเช่นกัน
แต่มีดวงจันทร์ที่ถูกหมุนอยู่ เมื่อเราทำแบบนี้
เราสามารถทำให้สองสถานะนั้น interfere กัน
และสังเกตว่าเกิดอะไรที่น่าสนใจมาก
เราได้ยกเลิกสถานะหนึ่ง
และเหลือแต่สถานะศูนย์
เราทำได้เพราะเราทำให้สถานะ interfere กัน
โอกาสต่อไปที่เรามีตอนนี้คือ
เราสร้างสถานะได้กี่สถานะ
และสิ่งที่สวยงามในควอนตัมคือเราสร้างได้เป็น
exponential ของสถานะ มาดูระบบที่มี
qubits ห้าตัว ในกรณีนี้เรากำลังแสดง qubits เหล่านี้
เป็น qubits อิสระ เห็นอยู่ทางซ้าย
ทั้งศูนย์และหนึ่ง กำลังถูกคูณกัน เรามีห้า
ตัว ดังนั้นจำนวนสถานะที่สร้างได้ใน
quantum computer ที่แสดงบน sphere ด้านขวา
คือ 2 ยกกำลัง
จำนวน qubits ที่เรามี ในกรณีนี้คือห้า
ดังนั้น 2 ยกกำลัง 5 ก็คือ 32 สถานะ
เราเลยเห็นดวงจันทร์เล็กๆ 32 ดวง
สังเกตว่าในกรณีนี้เราไม่ได้ใส่
phase ใดๆ ทั้งหมดเป็นสีชมพู ด้านที่ทรงพลังของ
การใช้คุณสมบัตินี้ที่เรียกว่า entanglement ในโลกควอนตัม
คือเราสร้างสถานะใหม่ได้
อย่างที่แสดงอยู่ทางขวา
ที่มีการผสมผสานของสีชมพู
และสีอื่นๆ ซึ่งสถานะนั้นไม่สามารถอธิบายได้
ว่าเป็น product อิสระของ
qubits ทั้งห้าตัวนี้
เนื่องจากเรามี 32 สถานะ
สิ่งที่บอกเราคือบางอย่างที่ลึกซึ้งมาก